♫
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT IS NOW CLEAR THAT FOR
MANY OF OUR ELECTED LEADERS
IT’S NOT EVEN WORTH HAVING A
COUNTRY IF THAT COUNTRY
COMES WITH REAL BORDERS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, YOU
MAY HAVE HEARD, IS ON THE
BRINK OF SHUTTING DOWN
TOMORROW IF CONGRESS CAN’T
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON
FUNDING IT THE MAIN
STUMBLING BLOCK REMAINS DACA
THAT’S OF COURSE PRESIDENT
OBAMA’S PROGRAM THAT GIVES
WORKER PERMITS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME HERE AS
MINORS.
ALMOST ALL DEMOCRATS AND
MANY REPUBLICANS PUSHING FOR
AMNESTY FOR DACA RECIPIENTS.
THERE IS A STRIKING
FANATICISM TO THEIR
POSITION.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS MUST BE
KEPT IN THIS COUNTRY AT ALL
COSTS NO MATTER WHAT.
FOR DEMOCRATS, IT’S
UNDERSTANDABLE BECAUSE THE
CALCULUS IS SIMPLE.
HAVING ABANDONED THE
CONCERNS OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
HERE THEY NEED MILLIONS OF
NEW VOTERS AND THEY NEED
THEM FAST, OTHERWISE THEIR
PARTY RISKS BECOMING A
PERMANENT MINORITY.
REPLACING UNGRATEFUL
CITIZENS WITH OWED BEAD YENT
IMMIGRANTS IS THEIR ONLY
HOPE.
ANY DEMOCRAT THAT’S THOUGHT
IT THROUGH FOR EVEN A
MINNOWS THIS WELL.
THEY CAN’T SAY IT IN PUBLIC
THOUGH BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
IT’S HORRIBLE.
SO, INSTEAD, THEY ARE TRYING
A NEW TALKING POINT.
TERRIFIC PEOPLE, EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM, FAR MORE
NOBLE AND LAW ABIDING THAN
YOU ARE.
HOW DARE YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT
THEIR PRESENCE.
YOU MUST BE A BIGOT.
THE ONE PROBLEM WITH THIS
LINE OF ARGUMENT IS THAT
IT’S VULNERABLE TO FACTS.
BUT UNTIL RECENTLY, THERE
REALLY WERE FEW RELIABLE
NUMBERS ON CRIMES COMMITTED
BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
THIS ALLOWED DEMOCRATS TO
PRETEND THAT EVERY PERSON
WHO SNEAKS ACROSS OUR BORDER
GOES ON TO BECOME A HEART
SURGEON OR A MEMBER OF SEAL
TEAM 6.
WE HAVE THE DATA NOW AND IT
TURNS OUT SURPRISE SURPRISE
THEY HAVE BEEN LYING TO YOU.
IN THE BORDER STATE OF
ARIZONA, FOR EXAMPLE,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMMIT
TWO AND A HALF TIMES AS MANY
MURDERS AS AMERICAN CITIZENS
DO.
THEY ARE ALMOST 50% MORE
LIKELY TO BE IN GANGS.
THEY COMMIT MORE ARMED
ROBBERY AND MORE SEX CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN.
OVERALL THEY ARE ABOUT TWICE
AS LIKELY TO BE CONVICTED OF
CRIMES OF ALL KINDS,
NON-IMMIGRATION RELATED.
THAT’S JUST IN ONE STATE.
IN CALIFORNIA, INANN ILLEGAL
ALIEN MURDERED TWO POLICE
OFFICERS.
HE HAD BEEN DEPORTED FROM
THIS COUNTRY MULTIPLE TIMES.
IN EACH CASE HE CAME BACK,
THANKS TO POLITICIANS WHO
HAVE ZERO INTEREST IN
KEEPING PEOPLE LIKE HIM OUT.
IN COURT THIS TUESDAY, HE
BRAGGED ABOUT HIS PLANS TO
ESCAPE FROM PRISON AND
MURDER MORE.
>> Tucker: SO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION DIVIDES THE
COUNTRY.
LOWER LOWERS WAGES FOR THOSE
WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD AND IT
IN SOME CASES COST AMERICANS
THEIR LIVES.
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
BECAUSE IT’S OUR MORAL DUTY
THAT’S WHAT OUR LEADERS ARE
TELLING US.
THAT’S WHO WE ARE.
JUST DAYS AGO THE SENATE’S
MOST CELEBRATED MORAL
PHILOSOPHER LINDSEY GRAHAM
OF SOUTH CAROLINA SPOKE FOR
THE COUNTRY’S ENTIRE RULING
CLASS WHEN HE EXPLAINED THE
RATIONALE FOR HIS VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION.
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
NOW, YOU’VE HEARD THAT
PHRASE BEFORE OBVIOUSLY.
YOU HEAR IT EVERY DAY.
IN EFFECT IT’S OUR NEW
NATIONAL MOTTO SOON TO
REPLACE THE OUTDATED AND IN
FACT POLAR OPPOSITE
SENTIMENT E PLUR BUSINESS
E PLURBISUNUM.NOBODY BOTHERS TON
WHAT IT MEANS.
IS IT TRUE THE LESS WE HAVE
IN COMMON THE STRONGER WE
ARE?
IS A MARRIAGE STRONGER WHEN
SPOUSES HAVE RADICALLY
DIFFERENT BELIEFS?
ARE YOU CLOSER TO YOUR KIDS
WHEN YOU SHARE NO COMMON
POINTS OF REFERENCE?
DO YOU SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE AS YOUR BEST
FRIEND?
COULD YOU BE BEST FRIENDS IF
YOU DIDN’T?
THESE ARE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS GIVEN THAT OUR
LEADERS ARE RADICALLY AND
PERMANENTLY CHANGING OUR
COUNTRY WHOLLY ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR FAITH THAT
DIVERSITY IS, IN FACT, OUR
STRENGTH MAYBE WE SHOULD
HAVE TALKED THIS THROUGH
AHEAD OF TIME.
SOMEHOW WE DIDN’T.
HOUSE MAJORITY LEADER KEVIN
MCCARTHY TRIED TO START THAT
CONVERSATION TODAY.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT HE
SAID.
>> WE DID NOT SURVIVE, GROW
AND BECOME THE MOST POWERFUL
CIVILIZATION IN HUMAN
HISTORY BECAUSE WE ARE
FOCUSED ON OUR DIVERSITY.
IT IS NOT OUR DIFFERENCES
THAT MAKES US STRONGER.
IT IS OUR UNITY DESPITE OUR
DIVERSITY.
UNITY AND PATHS OF
PRINCIPLES AND OF THE
PURPOSE THAT BROUGHT US OUT
OF MANY INTO ONE.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS,
DIVERSITY ISN’T OUR
STRENGTH.
UNITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
DON’T LET THE LEFT LIE TO
YOU.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN WE HAVE TO
LOOKALIKE.
IT DOESN’T MEAN WE HAVE TO
COME FROM THE SAME PLACES.
IT DOES MEAN WE HAVE TO
SHARE COMMON BELIEFS.
OTHERWISE WE WILL HATE EACH
OTHER AND THE WHOLE
ENTERPRISE WILL FALL APART.
IT’S TRUE IN FAMILIES, IT’S
TRUE IN FRIENDSHIPS AND IT’S
TRUE IN COUNTRIES, TOO.
YOU ALREADY KNEW THAT
BECAUSE IT’S OBVIOUS.
OUR LEADERS SPEND MOST OF
THEIR TIME DENYING IT THEY
ARE LYING TO US.
>> Tucker: A PHOENIX CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER RUNNING FOR
MAYOR IN THAT CITY AND SHE
SUPPORTS THE CONTINUATION OF
DACA.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I APPRECIATE IT?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: SO TRYING TO
THINK THROUGH HOW LEGALIZING
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY HELPS AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND IN ARIZONA WE
HAVE SOME DATA ON THIS
BECAUSE IT -- THE STATE
PASSED AS YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST
ANTI-IMMIGRATION LAWS IN THE
COUNTRY IN 2010.
AND THE EFFECTS OF THAT HAVE
BEEN STUDIED.
HERE IS WHAT THEY SHOWED
THERE WAS A SHORT-TERM LABOR
SHORTAGE OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE
HERE TO WORK, THEY CAN’T
WORK.
THERE WAS A LABOR SHORTAGE.
OVER TIME AUTOMATION MADE UP
FOR IT AND WAGES WENT UP FOR
AMERICAN WORKERS, COSTS
MEANWHILE WENT DOWN.
PRISON COSTS WENT DOWN,
EDUCATION COSTS WENT DOWN.
DRAMATICALLY BY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO GIVEN THAT WE KNOW THAT
WHY DOES IT HELP THE ECONOMY
TO LEGALIZE PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY?
>> RIGHT NOW THE CITY OF
PHOENIX IS THE FASTEST
GROWING CITY IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE ADDED MORE PEOPLE IN
2016 THAN ANY OTHER CITY AND
WE ARE CONSTRAINED BY OUR
WORKFORCE RIGHT NOW.
WE JUST HAD SOME FOLKS FROM
THE HOME BUILDING INDUSTRY
COME INTO THE CITY OF
PHOENIX AND SAY WE COULD DO
SO MUCH MORE IF WE HAD A
LARGER CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE.
WE’LL COULD BE CREATING
JOBS.
WE COULD BE BUILDING NEW
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR PEOPLE
TO LIVE IN.
BUT WE DON’T HAVE THE
WORKFORCE WE NEED.
AND THEY SAID THAT THE POINT
THAT THEY REALLY FEEL LIKE
IT’S CHANGED WAS NOT HAVING
ENOUGH PEOPLE THROUGH
IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
WELL, A LOT OF -- I BET THEY
FEEL THAT WAY.
NO, A LOT OF EMPLOYERS MAKE
THAT CASE AND THEY MEAN IT
THEY WANT OBVIOUSLY CHEAPER
LABOR.
I THINK ALL EMPLOYERS DO.
WHY WOULDN’T THEY?
BUT, IF THAT’S TRUE, IF
MORISM LEGAL IMMIGRANTS MAKE
A PLACE RICHER, THEN HOW
MANY SPECIFICALLY DO YOU
THINK ARIZONA OR PHOENIX
NEEDS?
HOW MANY ILLEGALS DO YOU
NEED IN YOUR CITY TO MAKE IT
RICHER?
WOULD MORE BE BETTER?
HOW ABOUT 10 MILLION?
WOULD IT MAKE IT EVEN
RICHER?
>> RIGHT NOW WE ARE
DESPERATELY CONCERNED ABOUT
OUR DACA RECIPIENTS WHO ARE
IN OUR CITY.
ARIZONA HAS 28,000 DACA
RECIPIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
GREAT MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY WHO WENT TO OUR
HIGH SCHOOLS, WERE EDUCATED
HERE.
WE HAVE BEEN INVESTING IN
THEM FOR YEARS.
NOW THEY ARE READY TO GIVE
BACK AND WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR FUTURE RIGHT
NOW.
OUR REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR HAS
STEPPED UP AND SAID THEY’RE
AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
ECONOMY.
WE WANT THEM TO STAY.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
NO BUT YOU JUST SAID, I JUST
WANT TO GET TO THE NUMBER OF
IT THOUGH BECAUSE I THINK
IT’S A BIG DEAL.
WOULD YOU LEGALIZE PEOPLE.
THEY VOTE, THEY BRING THEIR
RELATIVES.
IT CHANGES THE PLACE, MAYBE
FOR THE BETTER, MAYBE TO THE
WORSE.
WE SHOULD BE CLEAR ABOUT THE
EFFECTS I THINK YOU WOULD
AGREE.
IF BRINGING IN MORE PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY AND MAKING THEM
CITIZENS MAKES YOU MORE
PROSPEROUS THEN WHY WOULDN’T
YOU BRING IN 10 MILLION AND
BECOME REALLY REALLY RICH.
WOULD THAT WORK?
>> IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
AMAZING CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: RIGHT?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF
THE DATA FROM FORWARD DOT
U.S. MARK ZUCKERBERG’S
ORGANIZATION.
>> Tucker: I BET.
>> SO MANY OF THE
ENTREPRENEURS WHO BUILT OUR
TECH ECONOMY CAME HERE
THROUGH IMMIGRATION.
AND WE IN PHOENIX ARE
DESPERATE FOR MORE PEOPLE IN
ENGINEERING AND COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY BIG TECH
COMPANIES WERE STARTED BY
PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA?
LATIN AMERICA?
>> SO, RIGHT NOW I’M SITTING
IN PHOENIX, ARIZONA, VERY
CLOSE TO A COMPANY CALLED
FOR TIS WHO WAS STARTED BY A
GENTLEMAN FROM PANAMA.
IT’S ONE OF OUR TOP
ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN
THIS COMMUNITY AND THINK
ACTUALLY ARE ONE OF OUR
LARGEST EMPLOYERS OF AT RISK
VETERANS.
A WONDERFUL SUCCESS STORY.
>> Tucker: I BET HE IS A
GREAT GUY AND THE COMPANY IS
GREAT HOW MANY BIG TECH
COMPANIES WERE STARTED BY
THE IMMIGRANTS THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT SINCE YOU
BROUGHT IT UP?
HOW MANY?
>> IF YOU LOOK WE HAVE SO
MANY SUCCESS STORIES IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND SOME OF THEM
HAVE GOTTEN NATIONAL
ATTENTION.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO I JUST WANT TO BE -- WITH
RESPECT, I’M NOT ATTACKING
IMMIGRANTS.
I LIKE IMMIGRANTS.
I’M SURE A LOT OF THESE
BUT PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE,
WHO ARE BORN HERE WHO ARE
CITIZENS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW THE EFFECTS OF THIS.
SO HOW MANY IS THE OPTIMUM
NUMBER?
IF BRINGING IN PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY AND MAKES YOU MORE
PROSPEROUS WHAT’S THE IDEAL
NUMBER WE SHOULD GIVE
CITIZENSHIP TO?
>> OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
COMMUNITY WAS BUILT BY
IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: OKAY YOU ARE NOT.
>> WE HAVE SOME STORIES IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: STORIES.
I AM ASKING FOR FACTS.
I THINK IT’S FAIR TO ASK FOR
FACTS.
RESEARCHER GOT AHOLD OF THE
CONVICTION NUMBERS WHICH THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE STATE OF
ARIZONA HAS HIDDEN FROM THE
POPULATION BECAUSE IT’S
LYING TO THE POPULATION
ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
IMMIGRATION AS YOU KNOW.
AND HE FOUND THAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE STATE OF
ARIZONA WERE MORE THAN TWICE
AS LIKELY TO COMMIT MURDER
AND OVERALL FAR MORE LIKELY
TO COMMIT CRIMES OF ALL
KINDS.
NOT IMMIGRATION CRIMES BUT
VIOLENT AND PROPERTY CRIMES.
SO GIVEN THAT THOSE ARE
FACTS, HOW CAN YOU REASSURE
THE RESIDENTS, LEGAL
RESIDENTS OF ARIZONA OF ALL
BACKGROUND THAT THIS IS GOOD
FOR THEM.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND.
>> WE IN CITIES THROUGHOUT
OUR COMMUNITY HAVE SEEN
GREAT SUCCESS STORIES WHEN
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
WORK WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND THERE IS
TRUST.
SO WE HAVE HAD FOLKS WHO DID
NOT HAVE LEGAL IMMIGRATION
STATUS BUT WERE WILLING TO
WORK WITH OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND HAVE BEEN
VERY IMPORTANT IN HELPING US
PARTICULAR WHETHER I
DRUG-RELATED CRIMES.
>> Tucker: BUT DO YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE -- DO YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REALITY OF
WHAT I JUST SAID SO THIS
STUDY WHICH GOT AHOLD OF
ARIZONA’S STATE NUMBERS,
WHICH I THINK ARE
LEGITIMATE, SAYS THAT PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY IN ARIZONA ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT
SERIOUS CRIME.
DO YOU NOT BELIEVE THAT?
OR ARE YOU JUST IGNORING IT
OR WHAT’S YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT?
>> SO I JUST RECEIVED THE
ARREST AND CRIME DATA FROM
THE LAST CALENDAR YEAR 2017
FOR THE CITY OF PHOENIX.
AND THAT WASN’T WHAT WE
FOUND IN THE CITY OF
PHOENIX.
UNFORTUNATELY, VIOLENT CRIME
WAS LED BY PEOPLE WHO LIVE
HERE AND WHO WERE BORN HERE.
>> Tucker: THAT’S NOT THE
QUESTION.
PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE
ILLEGALLY MORE LIKELY OR
LESS LIKELY TO COMMIT
SERIOUS CRIMES IN THE CITY
OF PHOENIX.
ARE YOU SAYING THEY WERE
LESS LIKELY?
I DON’T THINK THAT’S WHAT
THE NUMBERS SHOW.
>> OUR 2017 NUMBERS TELL A
VERY DIFFERENT STORY THAN
THE STORY THAT THAT
RESEARCHER IS TELLING YOU.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ROUX
SAYING JUST TO BE CLEAR ARE
YOU SAYING HAVE YOU SEEN
NUMBERS IN THE CITY OF
PHOENIX PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY WERE LESS LIKELY
TO COMMIT SERIOUS CRIMES
THAN CITIZENS?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
I WANT TO GET YOU ON THE
RECORD.
>> WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
>> Tucker: OH, YOU ARE
SLIPPING OUT OF THE
QUESTION.
I AM ASKING A VERY SIMPLE
QUESTION AND YOU ARE NOT
GIVING ME A REAL ANSWER AND
I THINK THAT TELLS THE WHOLE